el esequibo la manzana de la discordia
entre guyana y venezuela el territorio
de 159 mil kilómetros cuadrados
corresponde a dos tercios de la
superficie de guyana es un área rica en
petróleo minerales y biodiversidad
venezuela reclama su soberanía en la
zona porque formó parte de la
organización territorial colonial y se
amparan el uti possidetis iuris un
principio legal del derecho
internacional que otorga a los estados
el control de territorios que les
pertenecen geográfica e históricamente
mientras que guyana defiende que el
territorio fue adquirido por grán
bretaña en 1814 mediante un tratado con
países bajos ante la poca claridad de
los límites el explorador robert john
burck por encargo de londres realizó un
trazado que ampliaba el control
británico una línea que se fue
extendiendo en otras etapas el primer
reclamo lo hizo venezuela en 1814
denunciando la incursión del imperio
británico y con el apoyo de eeuu bajo la
doctrina monroe que reclamaba una
américa para los americanos empujada por
washington venezuela aceptó recurrir a
un arbitraje internacional que desembocó
en el llamado laudo arbitral de parís en
este fallo fijó los límites actuales
pero caracas no lo reconoce luego de que
en 1949 se conociera documentación sobre
un presunto arreglo político entre
estadounidenses británicos y el jurista
ruso friedreich martens el 17 de febrero
de 1966 tres meses antes de la
independencia de guyana se firmó el
acuerdo de ginebra tratado aún vigente
que reconoce el reclamo de venezuela y
busca encontrar soluciones ese pacto
mantuvo el statu quo pero no resolvió la
disputa en la cual se reavivó bajo la
presidencia de hugo chávez y más aún
desde 2015 cuando fueron descubiertos
sus vastos yacimientos petrolíferos en
guyana en 2018
georgetown introdujo un reclamo ante la
corte internacional de justicia que en
diciembre de 2020 se declaró competente
para fallar sobre la legitimidad del
auto de parís pero venezuela considera
nulo ese laudo y no reconoce la
intervención de la sej j
caracas insiste en su reclamo de
soberanía y en enero de este año elevó
las tensiones al detener a dos barcos
pesqueros guyaneses acusándolos de
navegar en aguas soberanas venezolanas
así la disputa que ha tenido altos y
bajos a lo largo de la historia parece
lejos de resolverse en el corto plazo
[Música]